this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business
check out Squarespace through the link
in the description below more on them in
a bit if you put all your Hot Wheels in
a bag close your eyes and choose one at
random you're likely to find a car maker
with whom this guy had some sort of
rivalry or grudge today's protagonist
was born with an unquenchable thirst for
speed and unbridled passion for winning
and the resolve to design and build the
most powerful engines the world has ever
seen to achieve these dreams it was only
natural that hit create a few enemies
along the way his motto was think and
act as a winner that's how you will
achieve your objective his favorite car
was the one I haven't designed yet his
name was Enzo Ferrari a name that needs
no further introduction Enzo and Zellmer
Ferrari was born in Modena northern
Italy on February the 18th 1898 due to
heavy snowfall his parents had to wait
two days before the birth could be
recorded
mama doe geezer came from a wealthy
family of landowners while dad Alfredo
had set up a mechanic's workshop
employing 30 workers in providing metal
pots to the national railways Enzo was
the youngest of two sons with older
brother Alfredo jr. nicknamed Dino he
shared several passions the earliest one
was for sports journalism at the tender
age of nine and Zoe had one of his
articles published by the largest
national sports paper in Italy into
Milan defeats Modena seven to one next
Enzo wanted to become an opera singer
every Saturday night a dad would take
Enzo and Dino to the theater as Enzo
fell in love with every other girl who
could hit a high note he figured the
best chance for him to score with the
ladies of the stage was to become a
tenor
Enzo's third and most enduring passion
was simply speed since a very young age
the Ferrari brothers could be seen
whizzing around Modena on their roller
skates and bicycles but it was clear
this was never enough in 1908 Alfredo
took the tube or
through a motor race in nearby Bologna
it was a revelation a new obsession that
slowly started replacing all other
interests Enzo and eNOS spent the
following years building confidence on
rickety motorcycles and practicing their
autographs already thinking about their
successes but then calendars turned to
May 1915 when Italy joined the on chance
in World War 1 Dino is drafted into the
Army and sent to fight the
austro-hungarians he was exposed to many
dangers of course but the one that
proved most lethal did not carry rifles
or bayonets in 1916 an outbreak of the
flu claimed the boy's life if that
wasn't enough the same epidemic may have
been the cause for alfredo senior's
death during that same year in the span
of just a few months Enzo had lost his
beloved big brother and father
moreover the family business had
collapsed and the young Ferrari had to
provide for his mother and himself
Enzo it dropped out of school and found
a job as an instructor at a school for
metal workers but the experience didn't
last long he was soon over the age of 18
and it was time for him to be
conscripted to Enzo was assigned to the
third regiment of Alpine artillery
thanks to his skill as a mechanic and
metal worker he was assigned the
delicate task of maintaining and
repairing sophisticated machinery used
by the Alpine troops to carry artillery
pieces up to mountaintops and over
glaciers ie mules and donkeys
so yes Ferrari essentially spent his
warriors changing the shoes of horses
almost frozen to death on top of some
mountain somewhere now remember that flu
that had claimed Alfredo's senior and
Dino some believe it was an early rounds
of what later became known as the
Spanish flu during the winter of 1918
Enzo was unlucky enough to fall sick
early on during the pandemic however it
may have been a blessing in disguise as
he was sent to a hospital far away from
the frontline there he fully recovered
and was later honorably discharged
before the war ended that November
around the same period
Enzo moved to Turin seeking employment
as a test driver and mechanic with Fiat
Enzo did not land the job but was hired
instead by a much smaller company cm n
CN n stands for well whatever is put on
the screen now I'm not gonna attempt
that one by only 1919 he was still a
test driver but later that year he was
promoted
race driver and made his much-coveted
debut in the world of professional car
racing the occasion was the uphill race
from Palmer to another location that I'm
not going to attempt to pronounce but
it's this Ferrari was at the wheel of a
CMN model 15-20 running a four-cylinder
2.3 liter engine Enzo finished in a
solid fourth position not bad for a
beginner but he knew that he could do
better on the 23rd of November the CMN
team got him to race the Targa Florio
one of the most prestigious motoring
competitions in Italy that though was a
disaster the fuel tank developed a
serious problem which lost Enzo more
than 40 minutes after a brief stint with
the Sato Fraschini and so it was hired
by the heavyweights of the time Alfa
Romeo at the next Targa Florio in
November 1920 Enzo was driving in Alfa
4060 with a roaring 6 litre engine and
that got him into second position this
marked the beginning of a long and
fruitful collaboration between the
present and future masters of the
racetracks in 1921 Enzo scored another
silver medal without her a mayor but
also experienced his first accidents
this happens at the Grand Prix of Bray
Show where a herd of oxen had decided to
take a walk across the track during the
race and so steered away on time but is
4060 skidded off the road and crashed to
a halt oxen aside Ferrari met a few
obstacles in his growth as a solidly
famous albeit not stellar professional
driver in 1923 Enzo married his fiancee
Laura goryeo
he had been attracted to her by her
sense of humor and she had initially
been attracted to him thanks to his a
glamorous occupation as a jockey on
wheels but she soon started to resent
Enzo's absolute dedication to motor
racing Laura was concerned about Enzo's
own safety and tried to steer him
towards more stable careers Lorenzo was
too stubborn he related jokes that if
flora had had a way he would have
switched from driving cars to driving
trams still in 1923
Enzo scored another important victory in
the city of Ravenna not far from his
hometown on that occasion he got to meet
two of his VIP fans count Bracker and
his wife paulina the rockers had lost
son during World War one has had many
others including the Ferraris bear son
captain Francesco Baracca was a
certified flying ace having downed 34
enemy planes during the conflict legend
has it that after defeating in a
dogfight at German hailing from Stuart
he adopted as an emblem for his fighter
plane the heraldic animal of that city
and after that victory in Ravena
countess paulina wanted to make a gift
to Enzo why didn't he adopt the same
animal a symbol of speed and power as a
lucky charm and Enzo agreed since that
day all his cars would be painted with
the emblem which later became almost
synonymous with his name and this is how
the rearing black horse first became a
symbol of a flying ace and then made it
to the logos of not one but two
legendary sports car manufacturers on
both sides of the Alps Ferrari and the
Stuart based Porsche the rearing horse
must have worked its charm because in
Enzo won yet another Cup the coppa
acerbo which brought him to the
attention of Italy's Prime Minister
Benito Mussolini who awarded Ferrari
with a knighthood during the same year
Enzo got to meet the big man himself the
Duke J was visiting a senator in Modena
and Ferrari was given the honor of
leading the motorcade of the prime
minister after the first stop Ferrari
was accosted by Mussolini's chauffeur
with a request could he drive slower for
the next leg of the trip
apparently Mussolini had insisted on
driving himself in his official limo
said that he might prove that he could
keep up with the famous racer it managed
to keep up with Ferrari but it almost
killed his passengers in the process in
July of 1925 Ferrari experienced for the
first time the death of a friend at the
wheel this was Antonio Ascari the star
pilot of the Alfa Romeo team who crashed
his Alfa Pete - while in the lead at the
French Grand Prix Ascari had been more
than a friend he was a role model who
would later inspire many of Ferraris
business decisions but the show had to
go on and the team needed a new driver
Enzo put forward the perfect candidate
Tazio Nuvolari
a promising motorcycle racer the real
experts among you will recognize the
name of this legendary driver whom
Ferdinand's Porsche described as the
greatest driver of the past present and
future kZO was Enzo's polar-opposite
physically diminutive but absolutely
reckless he did not have any qualms and
completely reckon
cars in order to get a victory thanks to
his talons the alpha team continued
accumulating trophies and so did Enzo
over the following years Ferrari won two
more Grand Prix's this time on an alfa
romeo 61 500 s s the biggest
professional achievements of this period
was the 1929 foundation of the Scuderia
Ferrari or the Ferrari motor stable this
would be the new official denomination
of Alfa Romeos racing team managed both
on and off the track by Enzo under his
direction the Scuderia participated in
22 races
winning eight of them and those wife
Laura may have disapproved of racing as
a dangerous occupation but she took keen
interest in the managerial aspect of
leading a motor stable she was
frequently seen at the garages and
training tracks sometimes providing
valuable support to Enzo sometimes
overstepping the mark with her meddling
we'll see later how this would become a
bit of a recurrent problem 1929 also
marked Enzo's first significant meeting
with the lady who became his long-term
mistress lina lardy a daughter of an
acquaintance Enzo had briefly met Lina
when she was 14 now Enzo was 31 and Lina
was 19 he greeted the girl was to pickup
line how did you get so beautiful in so
little time yes this is kind of cringy
but apparently it worked on August the
9th 1931 Tazio Nuvolari the new star of
the Ferrari team won the three provinces
rally a coveted cup Ferrari finished a
very close second
this event is significant not only
because it could have been another
trophy in Enzo's cabinets and not only
because it marked the rise of neva Lari
but because this was the last race ever
for the racer from Modena the tipping
point was Laura's pregnancy he wasn't
going to risk his life and leave his
unborn child without her father
Enzo's first child was born on January
the 19th 1932 his name was Alfredo aka
Dino in honor of Enzo's beloved brother
just like his brother though anzo son
would face an unlucky destiny
the little boy was born with a
congenital disease muscular dystrophy
which leads to a progressive weakening
of the muscles and severe disability
Enzo would remain extremely
to his son doing anything possible to
find a cure for muscular dystrophy or at
least alleviating his suffering
biographers have speculated that Enzo's
constant warrior dinos condition may
have had a negative impact on his
personality making him more somber and a
more short tempered person than he was
previously during the 1930s though
Enzo's headaches were still mainly of a
professional nature arrival sharp had
opened in town the maserati car shop and
racing team
the Maserati brothers had first set up
their workshop in Bologna but in the
early 1930s they had moved operations to
Modena just a short stone's throw from
Scuderia Ferrari HQ the Maserati were
basically doing what Ferrari had been
dreaming of doing but hadn't realized
yet building their cars and racing the
same cars onto their own name after
moving to Modena the Maserati seemed set
on humiliating Enzo so they poached his
star driver novel Arie during most of
1934 Maserati dominated Scuderia Ferrari
thanks to new Volaris victories on a/c
634 Neville re parted on by having
several bales of hay delivered to
Ferrari the joke being that Alfa Romeos
ran on donkey power rather than the
considerable horsepower of the Maseratis
someone like Enzo Ferrari would not
tolerate that level of trolling Ferrari
and his team of engineers set their
minds on designing a new car that would
put nuvolari and maserati in their place
now that was another legendary piece of
engineering the Alfa Romeo one five
eight or alfetta it wasn't long before
the one two five eight bagged a position
that's the siano karpin's a first and
second position at the Grand Prix of
Milan and a first second and third
position at the Grand Prix of Tripoli
all this happens during the 1937 to 1938
period years in which Alfa Romeo had
decided to formally absorb Scuderia
Ferrari within their ranks on September
the 6th 1939 Enzo Ferrari quit off
Ramaiya for good with a special clause
in his severance package which said that
he would refrain from using the word
Ferrari in any mechanical car
manufacturing or racing enterprise and
so he did naming his newly founded
company AAC which stands for the name
that I'm putting up on screen now
because well yes in 1940 AAC debuted
with the model 815 which
looked like something Golden Age Bruce
Wayne would fill with gadgets the 815
participated in the Mille Miglia era a
thousand mile long road race with
legendary status but while the results
were not impressive very soon Ferrari
would need to face challenges of another
kind as Italy broke its non-belligerent
status and fully entered World War two
like many other mechanical firms AAC
would have to serve the war effort now
chances are that if you're starting a
business you're not having to serve any
war efforts and that's great news and
you know what else is great news today's
sponsor Squarespace I want to tell you
about them before we get into the rest
of today's video two simple things now
maybe you've got an idea for some
business or website that you want to
start and you've been thinking I should
get that out into the world well the
second thing is that the only way to
figure out whether that business idea
that you have is worth doing is to get
it out into the world and the best way
to do that is with a website and the
best way to build a website yeh guessed
it is with Squarespace
Squarespace allows you to create a
powerful website for whatever you're up
to if you want to sell something online
yes
Squarespace do support store
functionality so you can easily go in
set it up start selling stuff maybe
you're starting a podcast they'd support
that too or if you're starting a YouTube
channel well obviously you have to
channel on YouTube but you're on a
website on the side and let people know
what you're up to
it all starts on Squarespace with a
beautiful template you can customize
your heart's content or start from
scratch or move over from an existing
domain
everything is super easy to manage with
Squarespace and once you're up and
running there's a super easy
customization process and then there's
no updates there's no patches like you
might have to deal with elsewhere
there's just none of our staff that you
have to deal with Squarespace also
handle all the website e stuff like a
safe podcasts yes mailing lists yes
social media integrations of course
so Squarespace remove any excuses from
pursuing your dreams so just do it also
24/7 customer support of course they're
there whenever you've got a question so
go to Squarespace calm for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
Squarespace com forward slash buyer
graphics and you'll save 10% off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
and let's go back to Ferrari
in 1943 Ferrari moved his plant from
Modena to the smaller town of Maranello
meanwhile in Rome the Grand Council of
the fascist party had voted Mussolini
out of power on the 25th of July this
was followed by the surprise declaration
of an armistice on the 8th of September
as a consequence northern Italy would be
occupied by German and fascist forces
locked in a civil war with resistance
fighters of many denominations
monarchists Catholics and communist
partisans the latter were known for
exacting a sort of protection money on
rich landowners and factory tycoons
Ferrari was no exception and he
regularly paid his dues the left-wing
resistance brigades do not consider him
in a good light as he had gained a
reputation as a supporter of the fascist
regime he had accepted that AAC would be
converted into a plan to manufacture
tank components and other spare parts
for the war effort and he was good
friends with one Eduardo Weber the king
of carburetors staunch supporter of the
fascist Republic now installed in the
north the communist brigades had
tolerated Ferrari
for several months but in October of
1940 for a special tribunal had issued a
death sentence before they could carry
out the penalty though they needed a
final judgment from the man who knew him
best one Giuseppe Zanotti knee he was
the partisan who'd collected protection
money from Ferrari when XANA Rini went
to meet Ferrari he found him pale tired
and solemn he had just heard the news
that Weber the Carrera friends had been
executed by the partisans in Bologna and
so had a hunch that he was going to be
next in his later memoirs Santorini
reported a Ferrari did not appear scared
only sad that he would not live long
enough to fully realize the dream that
he had been pursuing for years to build
and develop his own cars after a long
intense conversations an arena settled
on a compromise if arari could donate to
the resistance half a million lira
that's about six hundred thousand
dollars in today's money they would let
him live Enzo asked for 12 days to find
the money and zannara me agreed later
the partisan reported back to his
superiors that Ferrari could be more
useful to their cause if he stayed alive
and in deeds he would be useful after
paying his ticket for survival Ferrari
proceeded to actively collaborate with
the resistance use
his factory to hide stashes of weapons
and ammo which would then be forwarded
to the partisans
he was even given custody of the
underground communist party secret
archives which he had at his home on at
least one occasion he even performed a
delicate mission he used his car to
smuggle out of Modena the fascist mayor
double agent for the resistance to
secret meetings with partisan leaders
the mayor was under suspicion from the
fascist secret police and Enzo was
risking arrest too by facilitating these
meetings on top of all of this Ferrari
had to look after the day-to-day running
of his company he had to adapt its
production to the demands of the
Ministry of War meaning by the end of
1944 most of a ac's out burped consisted
of hydraulic honing machines which I
have to confess I have no idea what
these are not their importance was to
the war effort but here we are
the Allies though they must have had a
bit of a better idea because they bombed
Ferraris plant twice in November of 1944
in February of 1945 after the bloody
conclusion of World War two if Ferrari
had two more reasons to celebrate first
the birther his second son Piero from
his relationship with Lina Lodi then he
officially changed the company's name to
Ferrari and released the first vehicle
under this name the Ferrari one two five
s the ones he 5s was the first of many
Ferraris to carry a v12 engine which had
two banks of six cylinders each arranged
in a v-shape at a 60 degree angle the
following 10 years were a decade of
success for the company
Ferrari scoops a third position at the
1948 Grand Prix of Italy and then went
on to win the thousand miles road race
in October at a lake of Garda Renzo
scored his first victory against his old
employers Alfa Romeo in 1949 the Ferrari
team participated in 49 competitions
winning 30 of them when the first
Formula One World Championship took
place in Silverstone on May 13th 1950
the Ferrari team was not there Enzo was
biding his time he wanted to make sure
that his Scuderia was ready for victory
a huge victory came in 1951 when a
Ferrari driver Friel and Gonzales beats
legendary Alfa Romeo pilots Manuel
Fangio this defeat was a tipping point
for Alfa whose leadership decided to
abandon racing for good
regarding the implications of this win
Enzo Ferrari said today I have
killed my mother without her out of the
way Enzo had free reign in 1952 and 1953
his Scuderia won the f1 world
championship twice in a row
naturally all these victories would fill
newspaper headlines meaning plenty of
free advertising for her Ari's other
line of work his regular cars for
private clients Enzo and his team
designed at least 20 different models in
the 1950s mostly in that distinctive
flame-red Enzo's eldest son Dino a
gifted engineer had been working on an
evolution of the v12 engine requiring
only six cylinders ie
the v6 1500 cubic centimeter
unfortunately Dino would not see the new
line of cars to fruition his muscular
dystrophy had been to generating his
body for years and he died on June the
30th 1956 at the age of 24 Enzo Ferrari
never recovered from the death of his
son according to friends and co-workers
his personality became ever more
introverted sombre and confrontational
almost dictatorial at work he started
wearing his signature sunglasses which
he never removed in public as a sign of
mourning Ferrari even decided to never
attend another race and he stopped
frequenting theatres cinemas and concert
halls later in life he made a confession
to a biographer shortly before Dino's
death father and son had been on a
mountain trip not bearing the thought of
watching him die slowly and so had been
one breath away from hugging Dino and
jumping to their deaths from a cliff the
only thing that kept him from doing this
with his other son piero who was not
even ten years old at the time
following Dino's death and so only in a
few peaceful years to mourn before the
start of the worst decade for the
company and that was the 1960s 1961 was
the year that risked ending it all the
year of the great Ferrari walkout it all
started with Enzo's wife Laura and her
increased involvement in company affairs
this meddling did not sit well with
sales manager Girolamo Gardini who
threatened to leave if Laura wasn't
removed from company affairs
yes Ivan next while Gardini was fired
but the sales manager was not the only
executive with a grudge against mrs.
Ferrari eight more key employees had
gardenias back when their friend was
dismissed the eight executives staged
walk out leaving Ferrari without some of
his best people and with upcoming
sportscar projects in limbo some of the
engineers even went to create a rival
company
ATS which still produces high-end
supercars to this very day racing wise
ferrari had a good year though he's
secured both the World Championship of
drivers and the International Cup for f1
manufacturers title in 1961 but the
glory from trophies could not hide the
tragic trend of accidents involving
Ferrari drivers in 1957 drivers
casalotti and portago had fatal crashes
in two separate races both of which
resulted in audience injuries - in 1958
it was drivers Musso and Collins who
died two weeks apart all these accidents
led to the worst tragedy by far wolfgang
von trips accident at the Monza track on
September the 10th 1961 crash which
claimed the lives of the driver and 14
spectators it got so bad that even the
Vatican was involved inside the pages of
its official newspapers the Holy See
compared Enzo Ferrari to Cronos of Greek
mythology the Titan who devoured his own
children sometime in 1963 Enzo had a
spat with one of his clients local
producer of boilers and tractors the
clients had struck it rich with his
machinery and too treated himself to a
Ferrari 250gt he didn't just cruise
around on weekends though he raced
full-speed at the cannon ball and
underground championship with amateur
drivers the tractor men had noticed that
the GTS clutch would give way too often
so he frequently went to Maranello to
have it fixed or replaced at the source
on one occasion he met Enzo himself and
he dared to give him some advice on how
to improve his clutches
Ferraris reply was predictable what do
you know about cars go back to your
tractors the cannibal driver he took it
as a challenge he went back to his
workshop and gathered a team of leading
engineers and designers some of them
were Ferrari veterans along the way they
realised that Ferrari used the same
basic clutch components as their
tractors only they charged them ten
times as much as existing clients it was
a revelation which only steered their
determination sports cars had a higher
profit margin than tractors and one
single sale would generate way more
continued
income through sales of overpriced parts
in November their first model was
presented at a car event in Turin for
350gt the tractor guy he was called
fruit CEO Lamborghini and Ferrari had
just created a fierce and worthy
competitor chipping away at the niche
market of luxury sports cars one of the
sporting events Scuderia Ferrari had
been dominating was the 24 Hours of
Lamoure this is a test of endurance and
car reliability more than speed after
Ferrari won the 1962 L'Amour a worldwide
press celebrated the events more and
more free advertising coverage for the
team Maranello apparently this angered
Henry Ford the second he alongside many
other American car giants was prevented
from racing by a self-imposed motorsport
ban in an interview Ford blurted out
that he spent billions in ads for his
cars but that mechanic ended up on
newspapers all across the world for free
thermic Anik retorted if mr. Ford wants
to be on the papers for free all he has
to do is buy a Ferrari this was the
initial salvo to an epic rivalry Ford
was intrigued by the chance to use motor
racing as a mean sprite car sales so to
circumvent the motorsport ban on
American cars he extended an offer to
buy Ferrari the Maranello company had
been struggling lately due to the high
costs involved in maintaining the racing
team and the increasing number of
competitors so Enzo considered Henry's
offer to acquire Ferrari he had one
condition he would remain at the helm of
the racing team with no intervention
whatsoever from ford's executives when
owns they realized he may not obtain
that he abruptly put an end to all
negotiations Ford was now bent on
revenge
his mission became to defeat Ferrari on
the track tossing the motorsport ban
aside he invested a sum that was ten
times what had offered to Enzo just to
build his own racing team he are driving
royalty like Carroll Shelby Bruce
McLaren Chris Amman and Cam Mars next
yet his engineers developed from scratch
a car to beat the Ferraris at Lamont the
gt40 the first deal took place at LeMond
in 1964 and it was a defeat for the
Americans the following year the
Italians came out on top again
Henry Ford wanted that victory at
any cost he bankrolled an unlimited
budget to his racing direct Carroll
Shelby who went for quantity as well as
quality fielding 13 gt40s of the race
four of the met withdraw but eventually
the strategy worked out three of the
gt40 s cut the finishing line one after
the other
Ferrari founds a revenge of sorts the
following year when three of his cars
achieved a similar feat at the Daytona
race but it was LeMond that really
counted in 1967 the two car giants faced
each other again and again Ford won
since that defeat a Ferrari has never
won at LeMond again Enzo surely did not
despair too much as his cars kept on
racking up trophies at Formula One Grand
Prix's but he still had to sort out some
new alliance that could keep his company
afloat enter the Italian car giant Fiat
the Turin corporation put forward a
Godfather style offer that Enzo could
not refuse Theon's pumped two billion
liras in cash into Ferrari demanding in
exchange 50% of all shares as well as
the designs for Ferraris engines Fiat
would also use their extensive plans to
mass-produce the road cars on which they
could earn a revenue but the most
important clause was the one that
recognized Enzo's full autonomy in
managing the racing team you see Racing
which would always matter to him
everything else was just sort of
collateral Ferrari gradually
relinquished control over his company
leaving the Fiat up to 90 percent of the
overall shares this allowed him to
concentrate on scoring victory after
victory in Formula One all in all it has
been estimated that Scuderia Ferrari in
both its pre and post war incarnations
collected five thousand victories
worldwide
[Music]
as Enzo entered his eighth decade on
earth he was forced to reduce his
overall activity but he also enjoyed
some well-deserved rewards in 1970
received the gold medal for culture and
the arts by the President of the
Republic and recognition for his
contribution to Italian sports and
economy this was followed by another
presidential honorific that's of Knight
of the Grand Cross of the Italian
Republic on February the 27th 1978 his
wife Laura died of natural causes it was
only at this point that he could
formally recognize his illegitimate son
Piero Piero could take on the Ferrari
surname and he was given a seat on the
Ferrari Board of Directors progressively
replacing his father and the company's
work and in his social engagements in
1987 Ferrari unveiled the last car to
ever be produced under Enzo's
supervision of the iconic f40 this is
probably one that you had as a Hot
Wheels toy Ferrari was now 89 years of
age and had been suffering from kidney
disease for a long time it was a very
ill and so that walked into Medina's
University to collect an honorary degree
in physics a few months later on August
the 14th 1988 Enzo Ferrari quietly
passed away by his own wish his funeral
was a very small ceremony that was open
to only a small number of family members
and old friends
so now the question becomes do I really
need to talk about Enzo Ferraris legacy
given the impact of his company the
incredibly high standards of his cars
and the victories of Scuderia Ferrari
the Italian Titan obviously led a
successful influential life Ferrari has
been celebrated in books films and
television either through encouragement
or outright rivalry Enzo has inspired a
generation of engineers and
manufacturers to push the boundaries on
what a car should look and drive like
well ends with an anecdote that reveals
Enzo Ferraris enduring appeal in March
2017 Italian military police busted a
big drug trafficking gang in a massive
operation that spanned five regions one
of the 34 arrested felons confessed to
one of their master plans to raise cash
for the gang the kidnapping of Enzo
Ferraris body from Modena Cemetery the
gang had already figured out an escape
route and where to hide the body their
plan was to demand a ransom of millions
of euros from a relative presumably
piero luckily they were stopped on time
but
crazy plan shows just how large he
loomed during his lifetime so big that
his corporeal body may never find peace
so I already have you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe brand new videos just like
this several times per week and hit that
notification bar see you find out when
we put out brand new videos also please
do check out our fantastic sponsor
Squarespace they're linked to below and
as always thank you for watching
[Music]